what's going on guys you know what
really grinds my gears when people go to
a Marvel movie and then leave before the
credits are over first of all it's super
disrespectful to all the best boys grips
and the nine-hundred special effects
guys who worked on it also there's n
credit scenes have you been living under
a rock what are you think I want to
stand up and just yell across the movie
theater idiot there's more so today
we're taking every Marvel end-credit
seen before Captain America Civil War
and putting them in order leading up to
our favorite in a segment that we're
calling rank um number 17 maybe the
worst end credits scene from possibly
the worst of the MCU films Captain
America the First Avenger it's a clip
from The Avengers saying that Captain
America is going to return in the
Avengers yeah Joey you know what I
should have left for that one I could
have beat the traffic coming in at
number 16 Thor the dark world
post-credits scene Natalie Portman is
sitting there all like damn Thor you
can't even send a text that's some
[ __ ] and then BOOM Thor shows up and
he and Natalie Portman's Jane Foster has
some sweet sweet makeout action and then
it cuts to a weird beast monster chasing
birds around
that part was kind of forgettable kind
of like Thor the dark world next up a
post credit scene from ant-man maybe
Marvel's funniest movie and one of its
driest end credits scenes it's a clip
from Civil War Bucky has a super metal
arm and some kind of vice and then
Falcons standing there and he's like hey
I know a guy I know a guy
you think that guy's ant-man the guy
that we just watched in the movie and
everything it is it's ant-man number 14
The Incredible Hulk
so Thunderbolt Ross is sitting in a bar
just de drinkin he's probably pretty
pissed off that he let the Hulk get away
isn't that the same thing he gave the
Avengers crap for in Civil War anyway
Tony Stark walks in and teases that he's
putting a team together putting together
first order of business replace brooding
at Norton Hulk with light hearted Mark
Ruffalo Hulk
number 13 Captain America the Winter
Soldier post-credits scene Bucky the
titular Winter Soldier himself checks
himself out at the Smithsonian Museum
and learns what we all knew since
Captain America the First Avenger what I
want to know what Bucky do after he went
to the museum did he go to the
Cheesecake Factory and then go hang out
in the Apple store and not buy anything
I want to see a movie called Bucky's day
out number 12
Iron Man 3 Tony reveals that he's been
telling his story to Bruce Banner
justifying Shane blacks love of
voice-over narration Bruce Banner just
sits there doesn't Hulk out kind of
falls asleep I was drifting arming but
ultimately I just remember sitting there
being disappointed about the Mandarin
what was up with that Mandarin am i
right number 11 ant-man mid-credits
scene hope Van Dyne she checks out her
wasp suit and gets a war machine like
T's for the next movie it's about damn
time all well and good but I seem to
remember the last time they did this
Terrence Howard got recast by Don
Cheadle hang in there Evangeline Lilly
and watch her back for Emily Blunt
coming in hot at number 10 Thor the
first one stellan skarsgård is being
shown a blue cube that no one will find
out about until Captain America it's a
tesseract and surprise Loki is alive and
I'm controlling him the whole time
putting the duration of Loki's death at
about eight minutes I think the movie
was over and then afterwards home was
like wait we can't kill Loki he's the
only good villain in the Marvel Universe
all right we're at number nine and I'm
sorry to rethink all the time I spent
waiting for these post-credit scenes
some of them are not good up next
Captain America the Winter Soldier
it's a mid-credits scene we meet a dude
named Strucker cool name dude who
reveals that he has Loki's scepter and
he's been experimenting on the twins
revealing Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch
the stage
miracle sometime I bet Quicksilver is
gonna have a huge story arc throughout
the MCU oh yeah he died bet you didn't
see that coming how's my sokovia accent
during college I did study abroad in
sokovia so number eight Thor - electric
Boogaloo just kidding Thor the dark
world
it's a mid credit scene lady SIF
involves dog drop off the aether with
the collector you know what if I wasn't
caught up on these movies that would be
a complete gibberish sentence anyway
Benicio del Toro debuts his silly outfit
and bleached white hair and we get our
first confirmed infinity stone there's
not wise to keep two Infinity stones so
close together
this one is Iron Man to Agent Coulson is
on the phone somewhere in the desert and
he found something what is it it's a
hammer like this hammer exactly like
this hammer it's Thor's hammer right
cool reveal but it's a teaser for a
movie that we already knew is coming the
Loki movie featuring Thor number six the
Avengers age of Ultron
Thanos gets up out of a chair puts on
the Infinity Gauntlet and says fun
I'm doing myself ok do it do anything
because as of now you've been around
about as much as a deadbeat dad I just
really opened up a lot of my issues
right there number 5 guardians of the
galaxy post credit scene this one gets
highly ranked largely because of the
sheer cojones on this one the collector
meets the much-maligned Marvel character
Howard the Duck and everyone expecting a
tease for age of Ultron goes huh if you
haven't seen Howard the Duck you got
duck boobs in there got to check it out
just for the duck boobs gross number for
the Avengers mid-credits scene this was
the very first time we saw a mid-credits
scene
Thanos turns around and smiles this is
pretty cool at the time was like what
the first time we saw fan house
but little did we know it's like the
most Thanos would do until the infinity
Wars we need a little more Thanos number
Iron Man Nick Fury shows up and teases
the Avengers I'm here to talk to you
about the Avenger initiative this is the
one that all but two of your friends
missed and that later inspired everybody
to sit there on pins and needles for
five minutes waiting for that other
scene and fYI this is the only time when
it's okay to look at your phone during a
movie hey best boys no disrespect you
know you my best boys number two
guardians of the galaxy mid-credits
scene baby Groot dances in his pot no
not the biggest reveal in the world but
if you don't think baby Groot dancing is
adorable
then I am Groot which translates to
you're an [ __ ] here it is folks
number one the top MCU post-credit scene
of all time the avengers the avengers
sit silently and each shwarma i'll call
back to an earlier reference a fun look
at the aftermath of the destruction
funny simple effective and led to a lot
of nerds trying shwarma good times
there's a shwarma joint about two blocks
from your i don't know what it is but i
want to try it well that was a nice time
what did you think of our list
what would you have ranked higher than
we did what should have been way far
down the list let us know in the
comments section below we want to know
what you think and if you stick around
til after the end of this
pisode there will not be a post credit
scene I want to thank you for watching
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter
bye-bye
watch is this accidental hit out-grossed
Thor Captain America the amazing
spider-man guardians of the galaxy every
x-men movie and Batman V Superman likely
prompting a new wave of all rated
superhero films so when Aquaman starts
throwing out sperm whale jokes you know
who to thank
holy crap Deadpool no it's for the
nation era Janet Jackson yeah I'm
[ __ ] Deadpool Wow you're showing
up in your own honest trailer that is so
meta